merci beaucoup
j'aimerais bien vous poser la question
suivante
étant donné les dernières événements
les situations évoluent et étant donné
les sanctions économiques sans précédent
contre la Fédération de Russie est-ce
que la position de la Russie a changé
par ailleurs
pensez-vous que le monde entier entend
la Russie mais également
votre avis sur les pour parler en cours
en Biélorussie et quelle est la suite de
la prochaine étape réponse en effet vos
questions sont assez complexes
j'essaierai d'être bref puisque vous
avez évoqué de nombreux questions
j'espère que le monde nous écoute je ne
sais pas si ils nous entendent
juste comment juste pour que vous dites
c'est très mauvais lorsque les êtres
humains meurent des civils des femmes
des enfants tout comme il y a 8 ans dans
le don-best et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons lancé une opération
militaire spéciale pour mettre en terme
à toutes ces
situations à l'Ukraine mais je suis
persuadée que nous allons trouver la
solution
les conditions sont connues sont un
cours d'être débattu avec
l'Ukraine
à nouveau la délégation
ukrainienne a trouvé une des raisons
pour lesquelles il fallait
des instructions de Washington puisque
ils sont pas indépendants
vont avoir lieu je vais pas énumérer
tous les points à l'ordre du jour ils
sont connus
pas admettre la menace à partir de
l'Ukraine la menace contre la Fédération
de Russie
la menace est existante dans les
documents officiels de l'Ukraine
l'Ukraine souhaite à tout prix intégrer
le temps
ne tient pas ça
pour ne pas s'élargir davantage et pour
ne pas
se compromettre la sécurité des autres
et renforcer il renforce la sécurité
leur sécurité au détriment des autres de
celle des autres je tiens que
l'opération militaire qui est en cours à
une Ukraine vise la des notifications et
la
militarisation vise à mettre en terme au
génocide
en effet le peuple ukrainien a le droit
à l'autodétermination
il est question de l'ordre mondial et
l'Occident par tous les moyens et c'est
d'esquiver notre position qui est très
claire qui se base sur des accords
existants en termes d'Architecture de
sécurité en Europe j'avais déjà évoqué
le principe qui a été
débattue à l'OSCE oui le droit de
choisir ses alliances étant à accorder
et reconnu mais la sécurité des
hommes ne peut pas être assuré au
détriment de celle des autres
et
la le temps n'a pas le droit
supplément de supprimer
pour dominer sur le territoire
on nous dit ne vous inquiétez pas c'est
le crâne intégré le temps ou
une autre alliance cela ne poserait
aucune menace et la sécurité de la
Russie mais
quel est le droit que l'Occident
s'accorde pour juger de notre sécurité
c'est comme si les Allemands
jugés
de la sécurité et à l'époque de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale et déterminer la
sécurité dans tous les domaines y
compris dans le domaine de l'énergie
en effet c'est là où est la question
l'Occident nous
des coudes mais nous entendent pas
et bien je suis tentée de faire des
comparaisons à l'époque Napoléon et
Hitler visait soumettre l'Europe
maintenant nouveau nous voyons qu'ils
étaient unis en semi-europe bon le temps
ça va de soi
de streamers
quelle est la vraie place de l'Union
européenne
il a bien forcé c'est tout
et maintenant
on entend des demandes des capitales
occidentales
on a tout de suite l'impression
de voir un tableau sur la scène
internationale un tableau comme à
Hollywood il y aurait un mal absolu il y
aurait de l'autre côté ambiant absolu et
le Bien absolu et personnifie
effectivement
associé
[Musique]
les personnes qui
est responsable de cette mise en scène
et bien je suis absolument persuadé que
cette hystérie hystérie passera nous
sommes toujours très au dialogue
à aux conditions de
respect des intérêts et des
taux des autres merci beaucoup
ma collègue je tiens à vous dire que
nous sommes en direct
je passe la parole au journaliste
américain
NBC à vous
merci beaucoup
de nombreuses personnes dans l'Ouest
comme étant
erratiques et isolé
pouvez-vous nous rassurer sur le
raisonnement du président Poutine
suit-il des recommandations et quelle
est la dernière fois que vous avez pu
lui formuler une recommandation
et comment on fait le président routine
vous
baser sur la propagande occidentale le
président Poutine ces dernières semaines
à plusieurs reprises et de façon très
détaillée à développer notre position
la position des autorités russes qui est
définie conformément au pouvoir
constitutionnel du président de la
Fédération de Russie conformément pour
voir du ministère des Affaires
étrangères du ministère de la Défense
dans les intérêts de la sécurité de la
Fédération de Russie ce travail est
quotidien
toutes les semaines
une réunion des membres du Conseil
permanent de la sécurité de la Russie
merci
excusez-moi attendez s'il vous plaît
attendez s'il vous plaît
vous pourriez peut-être terminé
la Russie et l'Amérique ont maintenu une
stabilité malgré des capacités
nucléaires
gigantesques pouvez-vous rassurer le
monde entier en nous disant que
la Russie
nous n'avons pas de
terrain
et des conditions
pour la pour des escaliers la situation
mais
aucune esplanade pour une des escalade
je voudrais bien que vous
écoutiez tous les discours et toutes les
personnes qui ont parlé d'abord monsieur
stuntenberg dans sa volonté de plaire
aux forces radical
a dit que personne va imposer sa volonté
à le temps même si le temps décidait de
déployer les armes nucléaires sur les
territoires de l'Est mais tout d'abord
le temps ne peut pas nous décider ou
déployer sur les armes nucléaires parce
que le temps n'a pas d'arme nucléaire
les états
mais ça position était très claire après
le président
nucléaires vous en souvenez
des affaires
le coq chez les Français
étant symbole national et donc il se
comportait comme cela elle voulait se
parano
il a bien dit au président Poutine que
la France avait aussi des arts nucléaire
c'était pas Poutine qu'il a dit
des discours comme quoi tout le monde
était prêt au conflit entre le temps et
la Russie et puis le discours de Biden
en répondant à la question s'il y avait
une alternative aux sanctions actuelles
il a répondu que l'alternative
distanctions à ces sanctions économiques
est uniquement la troisième guerre
mondiale donc j'attire votre attention
sur le fait que la guerre nucléaire est
bien dans les têtes des Occidentaux et
pas dans les têtes des Russes je vous
assure que nous ne permettrons pas
toutes ces provocations nous
permettront pas de nous déstabiliser
et sinon voulons pas de guerre nucléaire
dans ce cas-là il faut y réfléchir
merci monsieur le ministre
le monde voit que des civils Ukrainiens
sont tués par des bons russes
et le monde est uni pour condamner ses
attaques et les mensonges
les questions est courte mais vous avez
décidé de citer ce que vous avez noté
vous savez je ne peux pas commenter
des
choses qui sont inventées et des
inventions il y en a beaucoup
l'Europe
et c'est par tous les moyens
de fermer tous les médias toutes les
sources d'informations en provenance de
la Russie sur les événements à nuclen
sur le déroulement de l'opération
militaire spécial et sur le fait comment
l'armée ukrainienne surtout les
bataillons en Asie se comportent avec
les civils lorsqu'il se retire il pille
lorsque les forces a donné ce qui est à
Logan ce que
cela et on commençait à repousser les
forces du crinianaba les forces
ukrainiennes ce sont livrées à des
pillages ce sont des pilleurs
nous avons beaucoup d'informations sur
des provocations à venir à Mario Paul et
sur d'autres
territoires de l'Ukraine
parlez-en avec des Arabes avec des
Indiens avec des Africains qui essayent
de quitter l'Ukraine on leur laisse pas
passer hier le Premier ministre de
l'Inde a parlé avec le président de la
Russie il était préoccupé du sort d'un
étudiant et indien qui a péri à Carcans
il y a pas de force il trouve russe à
Carcans mais on voit que les étrangers
ne peuvent pas qui était la
et nous sommes nous ne sommes prêts à
les accueillir
je n'ai pas le temps pour pouvoir
énumérer tous ces faits
mais vous pourriez trouver les
informations très détaillées sur le site
de notre ministère de la défense
sur les
actes des néonésiens vous aimez bien le
mot tueur et bien là ce sont des actes
de vrais tueurs
pensez-vous que le président selinski le
premier président juif du crâne dont les
parents ont été tués pendant l'holoca
c'est un nazi
et par les néonésiens sinon il est très
difficile pour moi d'expliquer comment
ski peut être
en fait à la tête de la nation dans
laquelle il y a des
qui font des démonstrations et
même envoi des forces de la garde pour
assurer la sécurité de ces défis les et
il y a même des formations qui se sont
déroulées et à qui est beaucoup pour
pouvoir se préparer à la guerre tout
cela sous l'autorité de Zelinski sous
son contrôle lorsqu'il dit et que son
grand-père était ancien combattant ok
regardez comment est-ce qu'il signe les
décrets qu'elles ordonnances et quelle
loi ils prennent par exemple la loi sur
les peu et bien si vous regardez cette
loi il n'y a pas de peuple russe parmi
les peuples peuples ils ont dit jeunes
comment est-ce que
peut signer des lois qui enterdisent la
langue russe non seulement dans les
écoles non seulement dans le domaine de
l'éducation mais même dans la vie
courante
l'interdiction
même de demander des médicaments dans
une pharmacie en russe
par ailleurs en Crimée
qui fait l'objet de beaucoup de
discussions à l'ouest et bien il n'a
jamais elle n'a jamais vu d'autorité
ukrainienne tout personne maintenant
tout habitant de la Crimée
sa langue maternelle dans toutes les
administrations et bien j'ai beaucoup
d'exemples de nombreuses exemples
similaires vous aimez bien des images
qui marquent et bien vous n'avez pas
peut-être le temps de lire en profondeur
les documents comme il se doit mais
prenez un peu de temps prenez une
demi-heure pour lire les informations
officielles sur les sites des ministères
russes une journaliste française il me
semble hier monsieur Macron hier a
déclaré
[Musique]
est un mensonge et bien il a
entendu les réponses de sa propre
compatriotes françaises qui s'est rendu
dans le don de basse et qui a vu de ses
propres yeux des meurtres des deux
femmes qui travaillaient dans une école
et elle a bien dit elle a bien dit que
c'était une admissible mais
ses paroles ont été censurés dans la
presse et bien je vous invite à prendre
connaissance des vrais faits réels et ne
pas croire en scénario
comme quoi il y aurait un mal absolu
média corporation de la Chine
monsieur stuff dans je vous demande de
laisser la parole aux autres
et j'ai bien peur que Monsieur Stéphane
ne serait pas bien éduqué soyez
respectueux vis-à-vis de vos collègues
merci
Anton depuis Pékin à vous
merci beaucoup
aux autorités
ils ont dit que l'agression actuelle de
la Russie ne pouvait pas
réglé les problèmes
nous avons aussi entendu que des médias
comme RTE Sputnik ont été bloqués au
sein de l'Union européenne pour des
raisons de désinformation que
répondez-vous à cela
on ne peut pas concilier c'est fait
les assurances qui ont été d'abord donné
aux autorités soviétiques après russe
concernant le temps déplora pas vers
l'est et que aucune partie militaire de
l'automne sera dans des pays de l'Europe
de l'Est après les événements sont
connus
le président Poutine a évoqué 5 vagues
successives de l'élargissement de l'OTAN
à l'Est et à chaque fois la
de le temps et entier russe nous en
avons parlé à plusieurs reprises nos
intérieurs nous étirons l'attention sur
ce fait mais nous n'avons pas trop
trouvé en signal qui nous dirait que
nous pourrions être travaillé
respectueusement dans le respect des
intérêts mutuels
déclaration à l'os en 1999 et à Astana
de 2002
on a bien entendu que personne ne
renforcera sa propre sécurité au
détriment de celle des autres et que
l'intégration dans l'espace
de l'antique nous
amènera pas à la domination
Atlantique dans cet espace mais le temps
refuse c'est déclarations une très bonne
question à quoi bon le temps adopte
cette position il maintient cette
position je ne trouve aucune explication
exceptée la volonté la volonté de garder
sa domination dans tous les domaines et
de démontrer à tout le monde que c'est
le temps qui donne des règles
en Europe et maintenant même dans le
domaine de la sécurité globale
lorsqu'ils évoquent que c'est une
alliance uniquement défensive n'y croyez
pas si l'alliance était uniquement
défensive
maintenant donc le la frontière passe à
peut-être avant un passé
à la pompier du mur de Berlin mais le
mur de Berlin est tombé
maintenant les les lignes ont bougé ont
bougé vers les frontières avec la
Fédération de Russie il faut s'expliquer
sur ces modifications le président
Poutine a passé des heures et des heures
avec des dirigeants
occidentaux et expliquait de façon très
détaillée tout cela
[Musique]
terreau on est l'impression que les
dirigeants d'occidentaux nous
comprennent mais lorsqu'ils se
réunissent à part nous avons
l'impression que quelque chose ne se
passe pas comme prévu et il change de
pignon c'est triste
toujours ouvert à la conversation mais à
un moment donné cette conversation devra
commencer cela dit
que le temps et c'est de faire avec
l'Ukraine tout le monde le sait que il y
a eu en coup d'État anticonstitutionnel
à nucréal
après la signature
à part le président de la décision des
élections anti E6
et bien pourquoi vous avez commencé
cette ce coup d'État personne
n'aurait dans ce cas là attaquer les
rebelles lacrim la Crimée pardon ne sera
jamais été
mais nous savons que
pendant des années l'Ukraine a fait le
BG
géopolitique qui vise là Fédération de
Russie la Russie
[Musique]
puissance
cela a été dit dans ce cas là ce qui a
été également dit qu'il fallait
absolument détaché par tous les moyens
de l'Ukraine de la forussie pour pouvoir
affaiblir la Russie nous
souvenons le président a lancé
cette action nous le président qui
continue ses actions et bien nous
n'avons aucun manque de volonté
mais
nous nous sommes
contre toutes les menaces contre la
Fédération de Russie nous pourrions pas
l'admettre
allez-y
une question très brève
comment évaluer vous la situation
actuelle après les cours parler avec
lucane et quels sont les défis à
surmonter dans c'est pour parler merci
et bien je ne peux pas donner des
estimations de c'est pour parler parce
que ils viennent de commencer
qui mène c'est pour parler avec
l'usukrainien on va faire une
déclaration peu après la fin
France 24 Marc Perelman à vous
monsieur
le ministre
24 sur le front diplomatique la Russie
est très isolée il y a un vote aux
Nations unies à l'assemblée générale et
celle quatre pays se sont joints à la
Russie pour voter contre la résolution
qui demandait à la Russie de ces
immédiatement son opération militaire
l'OTAN est plus uni qu'elle ne l'a
jamais été depuis la chute de l'empire
soviétique donc c'est un fiasco
diplomatique pour la Russie n'est-ce pas
et vous savez c'est à vous de juger moi
je ne peux pas
juger des décisions de notre pays nous
pensons que nos décisions sont juste
encore une fois c'est très mauvais que
les civils meurent
mais nous pensons pas aux filles à ce
que diplomatiques je pense au talent
diplomatique de l'Occident
des milliers
sont morts aux alentours de 14000 de
civils sont morts dans le don-bass
personne à l'Occident aucun média
Occident
base pour pouvoir comment les civils qui
ont été
définies comme des terroristes comment
une des tirs
quotidien les écoles sont font l'objet
des tirs il y a des actes terroriste
[Musique]
8 ans du non respect des accords de
mines non seulement qui est ne mettez
pas en œuvre ses accords de minskom mais
continuez c'est
militaires et bien si vous pensez que
tout cela ce serait un triangle
diplomatique c'est à vous de juger
vous pensez que la Russie a commencé à
défendre ses propres intérêts
vous avez dit que le temps est
maintenant très soudé comme jamais et
bien le temps à chercher par tous les
moyens la raison d'être sa raison d'être
qui a disparu depuis les événements de
l'organisme le temps a quitté le
l'Afghanistan
non trouver un bon moyen de rallier
autour de soi ces alliés et bien
monsieur Macron a parlé de
l'autonomie stratégique et bien personne
surtout pas les États-Unis
permettront cette autonomie stratégie
stratégique
qui concerne
les mathématiques que vous avez et les
chiffres que vous avez évoqué nous
savons
quel moyen non partenaire occidentaux
obtiennent un
résultat il est 10 à tout le monde
qu'elle devrait être le résultat des
votes
il rappelle
s'enrougir qui a des comptes bancaires à
l'Occident ce qu'il peut faire avec ses
comptes bancaires et je le sais parce
que j'ai des connaissances à l'Occident
et on me dit
pardon moi mais il est question de ma
prospérité de mon bien-être et je vais
voter dans ce sens là oui voilà c'est
comme ça que
les triomphes diplomatiques
occidentaux
sont assurés je vous invite tout de même
à consulter les sites nos officiers
du ministère pour pouvoir juste lire les
commentaires de la journaliste française
qui a vu ce qui se passe dans le don de
base non nous ressentons pas cette
que nous sommes seuls sur la scène
internationale
pour ce point à se prendre de presse
Poutine a déjà dit
décision et les questions
du peuple
ukrainien
de la décision du peuple et de tous les
gens qui vivent à l'Ukraine merci
est-ce que vous êtes avec nous
poser une question au sujet de Pauline
skyya elle est dans sa dernière elle
était dans sa dernière année de l'école
primaire lorsqu'elle a été tué
dans les yeux et me dire comment vous
arrivez à dormir la nuit en sachant que
des balles et des bombes russes tuent
des enfants
j'ai déjà dit toute vie humaine
n'a pas de prix
sont liés
dans cette opération militaire ont reçu
un ordre très précis de Me viser que des
sites militaires même les casernes des
forces militaires ukrainiennes ne font
pas l'objet de tir
vous dites que vous faites preuve de
fortes précisions vos phrases mais des
centaines de civils sont déjà morts et
la Cour pénale internationale maintenant
a lancé une enquête préparez-vous
personnellement votre défense
personnelle devant un tribunal de guerre
ces questions
c'est pour votre
travail il vous faut trouver des
informations
émotionnelles
d'en poser les informations voulues par
les dirigeants occidentaux encore une
fois je ne peux pas
effectivement
à trouver toutes les actions
contre les civils mais c'est pas nous
qui étions
initiateur Irak
Libye les pays en Amérique latine c'est
ça que tout a commencé est-ce que vous
avez
documenter des mois des centaines de
milliers tués
ces informations vous avez lancé cette
guerre c'est vous qui avez lancé ce gars
donc le sang de Paulina et coule sur vos
mains n'est-ce pas je ne jouerai pas à
ces jeunes
vous voulez entendre les aspects de
l'opération humanitaire moi j'ai tout
dit
je comprends que vous allez choisir les
informations et les montrer comme cela
et on voulait pas par contre j'en
appelle à votre conscience
journalistique personne
âgées ont été tués par milliers par le
régime qui indient dans le don-bass
regardez les informations je vous prie
sur le site de notre ministère je ne
veux pas prendre le temps
avec des explications qui durent des
heures et si vous êtes tellement
préoccupé par les événements actuels et
bien il faut regarder les informations
officielles sur le site du ministère
merci beaucoup je passe au journaliste
suivant
[Musique]
la Russie a officiellement perdu 500
soldats en une seule semaine de combat
et d'autres estimations font d'ailleurs
beaucoup plus élevées
à ce rythme cette campagne pourrait être
l'une des plus coûteuses en vie humaine
dans l'histoire récentes de la Russie
beaucoup plus que l'Afghanistan la
Tchétchénie par exemple le message
officiel était de dire que
les Russes serait accueillis à bras
ouverts en Ukraine et que l'armée
ukrainienne baisserait des armes que
s'est-il passé
subjective
il y a toujours des pertes dans des
situations pareilles je l'ai déjà dit
prévision ne se sont pas réalisés
je pense pas parce que les plans n'ont
pas été dévoilés ils font partie de
l'opération militaire spéciale c'est une
question abstraite
cette situation ne peut pas être
déconnecté des événements
qui ce sont des relais depuis 30 ans
dans les relations entre l'Occident et
la Russie entre les États-Unis surtout
et la Russie le président Poutine a dit
irodies la menace s'est rapprochée
directement de nos frontières je
dévoilerai aucun secret si je dis que le
père Pentagon
est très préoccupé
parce que ils ont construit les
laboratoires chimiques et biologiques à
qui il y a au dessin maintenant ils sont
très préoccupés par le fait que leur
laboratoire peuvent tomber sous la coupe
des autres et bien les Américains par
ailleurs
ne souhaitent pas
conventions des conventions et qui ont
été signés de l'organisation de
l'intergation l'interdiction des armes
chimiques et bien il y a des bases
de le temps l'armée
ukrainienne a été entraîné bien
évidemment pour combattre la Pologne
souvenez-vous lorsque les États-Unis
disaient que il y avait une menace à une
miracle contre les États-Unis est-ce que
c'était plausible et lorsque la Russie
dit que la menace est réelle pour la
Russie on nous répond il y a aucune
menace
pour vous et bien c'est nous nous sommes
qui vont définir nos garanties de
sécurité
pas
des milliers de kilomètres de nos
frontières comprenez nous s'il vous
plaît
c'est une décision forcée parce que
personne ne nous entendez pas et on
entendait que nous mensonges que des
mensonges depuis 30 ans
un jour il faudrait que nous trouvions
un accord
mais à condition de ne pas renforcer sa
propre sécurité ou détriment de la
sécurité des autres un accord sur le
pied d'égalité pour le moment non
partenaires occidentaux ne sont pas
prêts et jouent au jeu de la du Bien
absolu du mal absolu
méthode et des mesures assez dures
diplomatique
ne sont pas justes et bien mais nous
avons déjà vécu à de nombreuses à de
nombreuses reprises ces situations dans
notre histoire russe actuellement il y a
une opération militaire à une chaîne qui
vise la Émilie tarisation qui vise la
des nazification de l'Ukraine
parce que les décisions du tribunal de
Nuremberg sont toujours en vigueur
nous avons plusieurs à plusieurs
reprises nous avons dit que
l'élargissement de l'OTAN à l'Est était
inacceptable il faut se mettre à table
avec la Fédération de Russie
à vous
s'il vous plaît
juste pour faire suite à ce que vous
venez de dire sur les demandes russes
hier vous avez dit que la Russie ne
demande pas la capitulation
ukrainienne
êtes-vous prêts à négocier avec le
président ukrainien et à quoi doit-il
dire oui pour mettre un terme au combat
souhaitez-vous prendre le contrôle de
tout le territoire ukrainien avant que
les négociations les pour parler plus
avancer est-ce que ça signifie
que l'armée ukrainienne doit être
totalement détruite
tout ce que vous évoquez avec beaucoup
d'émotions et bien permettez-moi de
répéter nous sommes prêts à négocier
nous sommes prêts à un accord
a demandé pour parler le président
Poutine a accepté cette demande et
ensuite monsieur Zelinski c'est ravisé
peut-être sur les conseils américains
ensuite il a changé d'avis et la
délégation ukrainienne s'est déplacée 24
heures plus tard les pour parler ont eu
lieu
et maintenant nous attendons le deuxième
round de c'est pour parler avec le
proposition
ukrainienne nous attendons donc cette
ukrainienne mais nous nous pourrions
jamais
toléré une structure militaire sur la en
Ukraine sur les termes de l'Ukraine qui
menacerait la Fédération de Russie et
donc l'opération militaire qui se
déroule actuellement
devrait aller jusqu'au bout donc la
proposition
ukrainienne devrait avoir ce point
Paris Darius rocheban êtes-vous avec
nous TF1
oui monsieur le ministre merci Emmanuel
Macron un Vladimir Poutine alors
pensez-vous que Emmanuel Macron et la
France ont un rôle particulier à jouer
pour trouver une solution diplomatique
et bien vous savez
ma
cron tradition
dans d'être intermédiaire dans des
conflits par exemple le président
Sarkozy et aider
à régler la situation
qui a commencé par en décret et
criminels de sa cache filet de bombarder
les parties de la
Géorgie et bien
le président
français
a participé activement
dans des accords
des accords domine ce que c'était une
étape très importante
mais j'ai appris
l'adoption de ces accords et
l'aval de ces accords par le Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU
personne
n'a rien fait au contraire
ils ont dit
l'Ukraine qu'il peut pas y avoir
d'accord entre
l'Ukraine et le don de base
nous avons et essayer de
raisonner nos partenaires français en
leur montrer en leur montrant
les accords de Minsk dans lesquelles
c'est noté que toutes les décisions
doivent être accordées avec
euh les territoires de deniers
le président Macron prend des
initiatives
à plusieurs reprises il a parlé
directement avec nos
entretenu tout récemment avec le
président Poutine par téléphone
et
maintenant il y a en entretien
téléphonique qui se déroule et nous
serions ravis si la France pouvait nous
aider à trouver une solution sur la base
des principes adoptés par le SCE
mais lorsque le président Macron
[Musique]
nazisme en Ukraine est un mensonge et le
fait que ce néonazisme
c'est pas nous en songe mais bien
parce qu'il y a des
discours anti en russe il y a des
crimes contre les civils dans le de nos
bases un autre partenaire de la France
Monsieur Scholtz
de dire qu'un Ukraine
il y a en gêne aussi et bien c'est pas
très agréable de voir que nos
partenaires
occidentaux ne reconnaissent pas les
[Musique]
témoignages du génocide et bien
lorsque par exemple on entend de la
bouche de nos occidentaux dire que les
situations paraît ne s'était pas
déroulé depuis 75 ans et bien vous avez
peut-être oublié
l'ex Yougoslavie
pour moi ce sont des doubles standards
vous pouvez faire tout
lorsque cela vous convient vous pouvez
quelque chose qui vous convient et
mettre sous le silence tout ce qui nous
convient pas je comprends que vous soyez
solidaire avec les États-Unis mais
l'ordre mondial ne sera pas renforcé
grâce à cela
[Musique]
vrai est-ce que vous dites à l'encontre
de la Fédération de Russie il n'y a pas
donc de
fraternité égalité et liberté dans vos
paroles encore une fois je rajoute fait
lors des conversations avec le président
de Macron le président Poutine a
expliqué qu'elle pouvait être des
solutions
fournit des armes à l'Ukraine
considérez-vous qu'il s'agisse d'un acte
de guerre et pensez-vous qu'il y a un
risque de guerre nucléaire
et
déjà dit quelques mots sur la guerre
nucléaire et ce n'est pas la Russie
qui a lancé
l'expression de guerre nucléaire
la France a appelé à Monsieur Poutine
que nucléaire des armes nucléaires et
monsieur sautenberg a également dit que
l'OTAN
rapprocherait des armes nucléaires de la
Russie
nucléaire donc vous tentez de nous
accuser une nouvelle fois de de ces mots
mais la menace de guerre nucléaire ou
d'utilisation d'un homme nucléaire n'est
pas pour faire la Russie elle est
utilisée dans
les médias publics en Occident pour
continuer à garder envie ce sentiment
anti russe et
la Russie agressée partout dans le monde
puisque nos athlètes ne peuvent pas
participer dans les compétitions
internationales
donc j'ai bien compris ce qui se passe
il s'agit d'une concurrence déloyale
tout simplement pour faire en sorte
que vous puissiez
gagner plus facilement dans le domaine
de la Culture des Sports et d'autres
domaines c'est vraiment une action sans
scrupule et une mauvaise décision et
j'espère que bientôt nous pourrons
calmer le jeu et que nous pourrons
discuter négocier de manière pragmatique
diplomatique sur un pied d'égalité et
j'espère
après des évolutions actuelles il y aura
un changement si vous pensez que la
Russie sera se dicte après cette
situation ce ne sera pas le cas
souvenez-vous de notre histoire nous
n'avons jamais
été soumis à quiconque
merci le chat
merci de me donner de l'opportunité de
poser ma deuxième question
monsieur Lavoine de mes collègues
évoqué le vote
à l'Assemblée générale des Nations Unies
et le résultat de ce vote que vous
connaissez évidemment ce vote
de sécurité également
ensuite à ses votes pensez-vous qu'il y
aura des
changements en matière de priorité
géopolitique russe peut-être que la
Russie
pivotera vers l'Orient et autres
questions
à la Russie il a pas d'Occident et vous
avez souligné l'importance de ces
garanties au vu de la campagne en
Ukraine
pensez-vous
que des garanties de sécurité seront
données à
l'oxyde à la Russie par l'Occident
et bien connu nous considérons que nous
n'avons pas été entendus depuis 30 ans
l'Occident connait bien nos
préoccupations
et
ils ne peuvent pas les ignorer
comme ils le font depuis tant d'années
du fait de pivoter notre stratégie nous
sommes prêts à travailler avec
tous les pays
campagne
les entreprises russes sur leur sol par
exemple
nous mettent sous une forte pression et
ses états considèrent que les Russes
doivent souffrir
je t'ai dit que des États-Unis ne
souhaitaient pas que les prix du pétrole
augmentent rapidement puisque la Russie
profiterait de cela voilà qui a été dit
par la France augmente
maximale donc
il souhaite sanctionner punir la Russie
en conséquence le plus gravement
possible et ceci aura un impact
socio-économiste et je peux vous
garantir que
ces problèmes créés par l'Occident
nous allons les régler
les garantie de sécurité elle souhaite
utiliser l'Ukraine comme un prétexte
comme un instrument
juste là pour éviter une politique
indépendante de la part de la Russie
de pays aujourd'hui arrive encore à
avoir une propre politique indépendante
donc c'est une attaque sur
l'indépendance ensuite pour venir
justement
de satisfaction
a écrit il y a
7 ans le 11 septembre 2014 suite aux
événements en crimés
et je suis en faveur d'un statut neutre
de l'Ukraine pour garantir la croissance
de son économie
[Musique]
de la Russie pour faire en sorte que
l'Ukraine fasse partie de l'occidental
[Musique]
devraient tenter de mettre un soin à
cette crise c'est également dans
l'intérêt de la Russie et c'est dans
l'intérêt évidemment de lui créer voilà
ce qui avait été écrit il y a 7 ans
étrangères
elle avait lu
mais apparemment cette fois-ci
oublier
la Maison Blanche devrait bien connaître
ses sentiments mais ils ne sont tout
simplement pas pris en compte chez
l'objectif est différent l'objectif
n'est pas la garantie à la sécurité de
l'Ukraine
[Musique]
diaboliser de miner la Russie voilà le
véritable l'objectif est il ne sait plus
aucun doute aujourd'hui merci Monsieur
l'avoff Merci
à tous je comprends nous émotions
je pense que le journaliste c'est la
comparaison des faits donc je vous
invite à consulter le site du ministère
des Affaires étrangères russes merci
beaucoup